you
all right we're ready to go
this is the fishing pole arena
a created tournament somebody in the
twitch chat here suggested I name it the
fishing pole arena so you know what that
means we're gonna have to at least try
once to go fishing
all right I don't think white is giving
me an option for fishing pull stuff I
should have played c6 sooner Queen b3
makes me cry my queen is uncomfortable
yes my queen is definitely uncomfortable
d6 is really sensitive I do not like my
position can I get that pond I hope so
I don't know if I could get out of this
pin I think I have to do this kind of
stuff which is really ugly their bishops
gonna reroute this is gonna hurt it's
gonna hurt I'm on this poem though right
God defend that and I can I get that
pawn I need to get that pawn it's not
going to be easy I got to do this I
think I have to give up the exchange
why didn't they take my rook don't know
my knight better be a good defender
get out of there man I gotta get this
pawn I'm not afraid of no discoveries
not afraid of no ghosts
Oh again that guy okay I'll go into a
pin take with the pawn give me this guy
I need an outpost square save him now
let's take like that all right I'll take
care where is my time
oh I just dropped my bishop they didn't
take it I gotta be at I'm burning
machine completely cut off
I cannot break this blockade much too
easy for my opponent to play
you
ah there they have some wheels too
yeah a gonner uh okay
get the get the loss out of your system
shake it up man
okay are we gonna have to crawl back
climb ah what could I have done better
I could have um not allowed that rook to
just have so much play on the dark
squares that's just too easy to pre move
that one out there time wasn't going
down any alright let's get back on the
horse let's maybe throw some well I
can't do the fishing pole here either
let's try this a big Vaughn Center let's
give that night a shove it's that night
close to dead
kind of know he's dead isn't he
fish up here now I got two on that one
mmm I want that game back I want every
game back that I'd lose I guess I get up
on here clean exchange and it will
develop and defend v4 and I say I'm just
up a pawn I'm of a piece I'm up a piece
and go with make up your mind don't get
back rank mated fight square I don't
need a flight square get your King
un'ytu you goof
h3 stupid move King f1 King e - here we
go
release the pressure against c3 and now
go after a 7 15 seconds let's scoop him
up
ok let's give him a shove keep improving
with the king I could take that pawn as
well let's just do that giving me stuff
more stuff no stalemate
and that's me I got those three squares
covered with the minor pieces okay
and we got two
oh let's see who we got next 29 players
in here now somebody anybody
quickly I may have to go berserk a
little bit here you can try to go
berserk Lind should I try to go berserk
the rest of the tournament the fishing
pole / berserk tournament let's try it
let's go berserk I don't know if for all
games but let's sneak some berserk games
in there
I want to challenge this guy actually I
want to focus on the e4 square let's
let's get there right now
castle also with my knight on e4 I could
give him a shove
challenged my night further
mmm fish appear clean on g6 let's do I'm
gonna take with the pawn I have a couple
sets of doubled pawns but
this should be good for me
it's difficult for them
to defend their queen side the rook has
a responsibility b3 is hit cannot be
defended
I got b1 covered all right they're
pitching a pond in this way their night
is still you know in a pickle let's save
that bishop
okay this is probably just going to be a
time when
get some material rook check I could go
here
I'm gonna give some checks let's get
another pond they're down on time okay
we got a berserk game in there now five
in first is 14
who has preserved a couple as well
okay
where's the guy that beat me why isn't
he up there I'd hate to be you let's
let's try another berserk
a king's Indian four pawns attack
they're going right after my throat
it's scary
scary but now there's no attack Bishop
block I have this
I'm getting that guy let's just take the
bishop actually I could have captured
the rook instead let's knock out the
knight and negate the night in the night
let's take them out take the rook out
next let's take them and run run really
fast no stalemates no stalemates careful
careful careful and mate next back
determined alright we got it we got a
cool five with that one ten 14 12 10 8
31 in here now I don't think this number
is going to change too much
20 minutes to go all right let's try
another berserk
it's a risk always
let's see if they give me the a file
they're giving me the a file Knight to
e5 now they're taking that out
sneaking a little pre-move try for a
fork they're gonna defend that open up
this side of the board but not too fast
let's try for this actually I got this
great cover with my knight could win
that pond not so fast not so fast let's
take him out let's defend here actually
just take that pond go here they're
getting that pond back
that's a check
want to put their king in some hot water
if possible I had Knight to d6 I think
at some point
I'm almost mated by winning a piece here
now they got that
this is winning just want to take their
night out for seconds is not a lot
okay I could pre move this out
two seconds should be plenty should
okay back to tournament got another five
and we're up there 15 with fire 14 12 12
12
a Kentucky Fried liver a berserk okay
we're gonna go berserk again this guy is
really quick Oh
oh that's that's that's nice to be able
to get that clean that's a full/queen
they resign back determine oh and
actually that game ended so fast so fast
they said no we cannot give you the
berserk points for that one there needs
to be at least seven moves I think
that's the minimum so I won but maybe a
little too fast a little too fast man
you got it you have to find that balance
it's okay to win but not too fast
sometimes remember that they resigned
though I didn't have it it was not I had
no control over that one the e4 is a
threat I have a check let's give that
night a shove give them another shove
such a bully such a bully
night there but we go here who they got
to go into a pen they're not going into
a pen they're giving me a piece I'm
gonna take up on here
Winston material throwing a punch at my
queen
I have c4 as well let's just take here
take there and do what next I'm gonna
get rid this night-night here I could go
in pin the night there is no night move
discover attack against my broker's I
could take the night in defend
let's just open stuff up get at the G
file
this is crumbling now sneak the cleanin
they resigned back to tournament 24 1412
24:16 14
I got a five for that one
almost at the half minute point or I
have half
at the halfway point what are you trying
to say
speak speak English a c3 huh that is
different let's get my queen on e7 there
and they're preparing for a push
there
it'sjust even-steven position let's get
a flight square in night there was
better and now their night is gonna sink
in here I have to challenge him if he
does that right away should probably
look to control this file what's that
move about
okay I get to target some ponds here
they're giving me a pond it's a big pond
past pond they could get their night in
here I'm prepared to give up the
exchange if they do that I think that's
what I will do and he's got to go it's
just too good
I got pieces to work with no that's
wrong I needed that guy around my night
better not get hit any more I could give
a check a timely check a fork I had a
fork there let's keep going
I wanna make use of a timely fork I
don't know how timely that was is that
the best move let's try this
I'm on the rook
and the switz check all calculated it
was all calculated let's just pick this
guy up mean - we got it back determine
okay 14 minutes and change
29 with fire 36 in here where's the guy
who beat me up in round one was that the
only game he played I would have
expected be 2 for them to be up
somewhere on the top just one game
Kentucky Fried liver
again the quick resigner the guy who did
not allow f4 to be possible or um f4 to
be possible what am I talking about the
guy that did not allow the
the berserk to work
Oh hiding huh
well you got sneaky stuff on g7 back to
tournament 34:18 13 minutes to go let's
keep going
Ren Gaara thank you for the resub 18
months in a row
preciate it man
just catching that now all right let's
keep going on this berserk train that
move about aah sneak attacks another
sneak attack how do you win how do you
win in this position c5 is what I should
have played all right hit the bishop
launch the F pawn give me something to
play with man
something something anything I'm taking
investing some more material I want more
can I get more I want me where's the me
I are thinking they're in a pickle let's
check careful King
we got discoveries and everything that
and we're gonna have a double checkmate
not clay
govern should be enough actually that's
not working let's try this again I'm
gonna take the rook with check then go
here and then me next that little c6
move I didn't get to share why I did
that I just wanted to plug that up so
one of their pieces would go there and
then their King couldn't make use of c6
otherwise I felt like he could have
relied upon that square somehow not a
hundred percent on that but 39:21
yellowdragon this will be a tough one
but we're still gonna try it
I gotta go with something I could play
fast faster than most openings caro-kann
they're allowing me to get this in there
maybe not the greatest pre move they
could take on f6 at any moment well it's
not Castle too fast do not want to get
mated let's take him out bishop exchange
would be nice and they don't want any of
that
what kind of exchanges can we get here
yeah they're gonna hurt me they are
gonna hurt me
clean exchange yeah whoo that was a
mouse slip I'll take it that was helpful
they resigned back to tournament okay
yeah they were gonna put some a lot of
heat on me there they want to play Queen
g3 pretty sure okay I haven't played the
fishing pole yet maybe we could do it
from the white end can Kentucky Fried
liver
again
pawns here get in a five okay I'll shut
it down let's go in this direction yeah
they're Knights gonna hurt me I got it I
got it offset that night
not a fun move to play they're so fast
it's a really fast player
really fast
is push this through though no
stalemates they resign back determine
wicked fast I think they're ultra bullet
rating is really really good Kentucky
fried liver they're probably an ultra
bullet player or not
all right let's keep going
um okay I guess we'll go for this beam
kiddo
ah they're trying the tricky stuff again
trying to take here take advantage of
the unprotected rook I do have that also
night here should be pretty good at some
stage take with the clean let's go here
I guess with this in a play
dropped a piece yeah this is gonna hurt
can I hang out at a pond I need to
I need to hang on to that pond
whoa they gave me this they missed that
their Bishop was hanging
where's my time though I don't have much
time
it's terrible that's a terrible move
got to just abandon that pond
I need to be able to make pre moves
you
this is great commentary what I'm doing
right here and I'm losing
oh they got my last pun holy cow man
I had to fight back a lot of seconds I
should have won that at the end their
King was so slippery got my rook pawn in
my F pawn man okay
a double berserk
all right we got to go fishing this is
the fishing pole arena I've yet to do it
no one's allowing me
no one is allowing me that was I only
wanted to do that if it was hitting this
tempo they went back like that
voluntarily all right so this is
basically yeah berserk one-minute aka
[Music]
hyperbole came
mmm-hmm they're still in a pen I still
have some space here
c4 isn't going away anytime soon I don't
think anchor up on e5
have some sometime äj--
why didn't I jump into e4 let's try this
I kept there oh it's made on the spot I
forgot I was guarding h2 I'll take it
54:24 954 25 24 let's do it again a
reverse fishing pole we could set it up
on the white side I think in a castle
stopping Queen c2 how can you do try to
shut down that bishop
I'll take with the Jeep on where's their
night going
okay they have a square now I should
have jumped in let's do this
go away clean where is she going
I nights or monsters I shouldn't have
captured let's get back into d5 Oh
where's their king gun open it up very
soon with d4 take my night out let's put
him right here actually that was a bad
pre-move it could've really hurt me
let's kill the night
away from some squares from the Queen
who has an odd move not sure what b4 is
doing get rid of the pesky night and
just tracked down this pawn my bishop is
really good
and get to the back rank close to me
I'll take here they take my bishop I
take theirs
that's a check not quite me what's that
mate
no just yeah I'm just guessing and
testing basically just just try
everything is that mate now let's try
something else
great strategy don't calculate just
guess make a move and question is that
me what about now
are we there yet are we there yet three
minutes and change
we're almost there we're almost at the
end of this fishing pole arena the
yellow dragons gonna slap me around last
time what was a Carroll Khan land we got
try Sicilian come on no man no one's
allowing a fishing pole
no one I'll try to still orchestrate
some yeah that worked wonderful attempt
you know can you show me later how you
um how you pull off the fishing pole
that was beautiful how you did that show
me your ways that was wonderful the
execution beautiful amount beautiful
love it I love it
you got a go Bishop you're just too good
that's a check
my knight could do something dangerous
maybe and get a fishing pole in this way
am I getting that pond bait it's just
bait
there's the fishing pole that's that's
the closest thing to a fishing poles
you're gonna see that's all oh this
night is on a rampage and I'm gonna
check first and maybe another check and
another check he's on fire that night
he's on fire
Oh Oh they really went into a position
where I could pre move out no that's not
me
it's almost stalemate oh you could do as
a stair stair ladder
checkmate that's all I've done after
let's do what it's late at night it's
308 a.m. you should be in bed sleeping
quit playing chess what's the matter
with you
go to your room go to your room no more
chess for you you're back to your
ridiculousness Kentucky Fried liver you
see that shouldn't make me laugh so what
my opponent started with 83 what's so
funny about that
and now I'm getting fishing pulled ah
yeah your opponent's good fishing pole
you too
whoa let's just get a square in case
just in case I need it
I'm taking that gonna get a trade okay
we got a queen train I just want to keep
things closed man please let's just keep
things closed let's just go over here
okay the worst is past I think you can
take that pawn no no I didn't want to
take that come on King
come over here check check
I just want a rook trade man and a mate
I'll take a mate and that's gonna be it
mm-hmm pairings are closed pulled off a
67 67 29 28 28 44 players in all three
two one that's gonna do it for the
fishing pole arena that did not see a
true fishing pole executed I attempted I
attempted but it just was not there
all right let's see page two three four
Kung Fu Panda chess five okay to the 43
of you good games oh that was fun as
usual and it has been a while already
you